hi
i'm kelsey butler with bloomberg quick
take
in the u.s latinos make up about 20 of
the population
but you wouldn't know it by turning on
the television or taking a look at the
movies
here to talk about latino representation
in hollywood
is actor comedian producer john
leguizamo
bienvenido john
it's a pleasure thank you for having me
thanks so much so we're just gonna dive
right in
we made some news you made some news
recently by saying you were gonna
boycott the emmys
so two uh questions about that
one did you catch any of the show and
two
what was behind your decision to not uh
not participate in the show no i didn't
catch the show
uh i refuse because it's too
disheartening it's too sad
and
there's so much talent who are not being
seen not being used and it just
it's painful you know and it's it's
a very reverse engineering problem it's
not the emmys that are the problem but
that's where you see it that's the only
place you can really
measure it because the problem is
they're not
making la and stories and not casting
latin people so how can we win
emmy nominations if we're not cast in in
great roles or in any roles you know i
mean there was nobody there
and and it's not like we just got here
we've been here for 500 years
so i don't want any more lost
generations i don't want
enough is enough for this lack of lack
of inclusion
latin people are 50 of the population in
los angeles
less than three percent of the faces in
front of the camera
less than two percent of the crew less
one person
is an executive that's cultural
apartheid in new york city we're equal
to whites
in population and less than one percent
of the stories in the new york times
or staff at the new york post at new
york magazine new york yorker anything
with the word new yorker we don't exist
that's cultural apartheid and it goes
everywhere across
america we're the least seen in
children's uh
picture books and we're 30 percent of
the the nation's
uh public school population
what does that do to a kid who can't see
himself who how does he know he matters
how how does he know that
that he can succeed if he can't see
himself reflected anywhere positively
and how do other people know to respect
us
you know definitely some interesting
questions you raised there
so as we kind of look at this then whose
responsibility is it to fix this problem
is it the creatives to either knock down
the door or go off
and make your own stuff or is it the
responsibility of allies
you know white allies to green light
projects to kind of
capitalize on the latino community's
you know interest in pop culture but
also to make things look more diverse
yeah well i think it is it behooves the
executives
it behooves the c ceos of companies and
corporations
and studios and networks to make a
difference to to look at their staff
take a picture of their staff i've been
asking for a month now take a picture
of your office and tell me where the
latinx people are where the latinx
executives and the new york times did it
they showed
how little representation we have when
we contribute
2.3 trillion dollars to the u.s economy
every year if we were our own country be
the eighth largest country
economy in the world so if we're
contributing that much i
want that much rep presentation in front
of the camera and behind the camera
so i i i think bad robot is doing jj
abrams company
is is doing a 40 of of their uh
staff executives and projects are all
going to be
uh latin people of color uh jason blum
of blunt house
is is working on creating a similar deal
uh you saw the oscars made it made a a
dent i think that's what everybody needs
to start doing
absolutely and i know that you just made
your directorial debut
in your new film critical thinking so
can you talk about you know why it's
important for you to kind of expand
what you do behind the camera obviously
people know you for what you do in front
of the camera but
is it important to add to those hyphens
oh yeah you know being an immigrant you
know we do everything
we all have five jobs never sleep uh you
know
workaholics uh yeah so you know i just
felt like
i think the the biggest impact i can
make is if i could start going behind
the camera and start
fighting to create projects because that
this movie even though it it took two
decades to get it done
even though it was a beautiful story
true story of five latin and black kids
from one of the tough neighborhoods in
miami who without
supplies without money with de-funded
public schools
no trickle down theory because that's a
myth
they became united states national chess
champions in 1998 and i thought what an
inspirational story man
here are these that what's really
happening in our communities
latin and black kids who are gifted
talented geniuses
in in their communities are not being
seen or not being nourished
and are not being boosted so when i saw
this story i was like i gotta be a part
of this you know
i got i gotta help make this and and we
raised the money independently because
we went to the studios
and the studios were white splaining
they were like you know
latin people don't want to see latin
people and i was like what
and they were like latin people don't
want to see feel good movies oh no no we
just want to see really depressing
suicidal stuff i mean come on man
so how to raise the money independently
and and this
this great man harvey chaplin who i'll
always be grateful to
uh gave us the the money the three
million dollars
and we had 23 days to shoot it
i want to kind of build off of that you
know the latin community has a really
big
pop culture footprint um i think
was you know one of the longest running
variety shows ever and that was in
spanish
the novellas are seen by billions of
people around the world
so to your point like what is hollywood
missing about
this huge audience that exists out there
well you know it
it's weird
did you lose me there for a second uh
contributed about 1.3 trillion dollars
to the box office to hollywood how can
you not
pay pay that back you know what i mean
uh
it's it's important that
they start seeing that and and and and
and we land people
latinx we win when there are metrics
when there are measurables
like uh like j balvin is number one on
spotify
in the world internationally he beat
drake why because you can measure those
hits
uh my my dominican sister cardi b is
number one on the billboard
maluma bad bunny my puerto rican brother
ozuna
uh uh camila cabello my cuban sister i
mean they're all crushing it because you
can measure those scans
we're killing it in baseball because we
have stats in politics aoc
uh uh jessica ramos catalina cruz cindy
polo debbie
marcus powell uh we're winning where you
can measure votes but where when we have
to rely
on an executive's opinion or taste we
lose because
they don't know us they don't care about
about us
you know and and that's that's where it
ends
well said well i know you're a man of
the people so i'm gonna throw it to a
question from the audience
um how do we get more education
um for latinos in schools and as well
when it comes to the acting world yeah
well schools is is a wild thing i mean
i i think we need to change textbooks
and to include our contributions because
we have
we're the only ethnic group that that's
bought in every single war america has
ever had we're the most decorated
minority
in every single war and i'm talking
about the american revolutionary war
where 10 000 unknown latino patriots
fought
out of 80 000 so we were one in eight i
want to see that information in a
textbook
20 000 was fought in the civil war and
we had
officers from puerto rico in chile and
we had the first admiral i want to see
that in textbooks
um also you know with 30
obviously of the population of public
schools
and and and we know what the magic
bullet is for public schools
we got great teachers in america we have
the buildings we need money
we need people like betsy devos to stop
defunding public schools
and put that money in public schools and
stop trying to do vouchers
because charter schools are beautiful
but they only take care of the elite
kids in those neighborhoods what happens
to the rest of us we fall through the
cracks
so just put money in public schools
that's the secret bullet
we got the teachers they need we need
more teachers and smaller classrooms
and and we need to be prepared for those
gold standard tests
and and they need to do that in junior
high school middle school
we should be we should know how to do
those tests in new york city
we have three gold standard public
schools brooklyn tech
um bronx cyber bronx science and
stuyvesant
and and we latin and black children are
seven percent of the population in those
schools
why because no one told us no one told
the parents they don't know that the
kids have to work on these
on these tests and get tutored so that
they can pass that test and get
to the schools that get you out of the
ghetto
yeah no definitely a lot of interesting
points there
you know i want to circle back to one
thing that you said about
um some of the latin history that exists
latinos fighting
in the revolutionary war in the civil
war
um you know in your show latin history
for morons which was your one-man show
in new york
it was changed into a netflix it turned
into a netflix special
you know one of the things that stood
out to me was that you said
um you were almost embarrassed about
some of the things that you didn't know
about the latino community
was that kind of what drove you to bring
that to a mainstream audience there
yeah i mean i i kind of grew up in in
america feeling less than
you know that was the the the
microaggressions
and and and the messaging that you get
when when you're not visible when you
don't see yourself
as a as a hero uh in a comic book
when you don't see yourself as a hero in
a in a tv show
or in a history book i mean how do you
know what your self-worth is how do you
build that out of thin air
so i always felt less than so when i
started learning all about our
contributions to america it was
i felt betrayed i felt betrayed by my
education i felt betrayed
by by the media i felt betrayed by the
textbooks
because we our contributions are huge i
mean first of all we didn't just get
here we got here 500 years ago
we discovered america we built it the
british took it from us
america took the rest of the southwest
from us but before that we were
the greatest civilizations everywhere
the incas the mayas the aztecs the
comanche apache
and and then we didn't stop there we
kept building america you know
120 000 must forward in world war one
500
000 of us fought in world war ii with
incredible amounts of heroes like this
guy gilbusques
this mexican ambassador who saved 40 000
jews
in world war ii in france by renting two
giant churches and hiding them
and then get bringing them to mexico and
giving them asylum
these are great we have millions of
stories like these
and they should be in history textbooks
they should be movies they should be tv
shows
they should be everywhere so that we see
ourselves
as contributing to the making and making
the america incredible
and then other people see us so we're
not vulnerable to
what happened in el paso where 23 latin
people just being latin
were mowed down and shot or or or or
pulse
the majority of the lgtbq community
there was latinx
you know i just don't want to see us
being vulnerable anymore
yeah and to your point about
contributions to america
i want to shift gears and talk a little
bit about politics so i know you're very
vocal politically
you stumped for biden recently um
you know talk to me a little bit about
what you want to say to that block of
latino voters as we come up on this
presidential election
yeah well you're so right about that i
mean we're the largest voting bloc
with 32 million registered voters 73
of us are democrat and the rest are
republican um
i i want to say to my republican latinx
people uh
think about the rest of us think about
the more vulnerable latino people
stop thinking about yourselves in your
pockets and and reach across the aisle
and vote for biden
and i'm telling mostly to my my
republican cuban brothers and sisters
in in miami and florida think about the
rest of us i mean you got here
through asylum and and being refugees
and and you should extend that courtesy
to our mexican and central american
brothers and sisters coming over
uh and vote for biden and i'm telling my
puerto rican brothers and sisters who
are
who are in florida to flip that state
register and vote
i know you i know you don't want to give
up your id to puerto rico but just give
it up for this moment
and then go back to getting your id but
just vote register and vote because
you you don't want trump throwing paper
towels at the next terrible hurricane
at you you don't want him trading puerto
rico for
for gree for greenland or iceland you
you you don't want that
so register and vote and i'm asking all
latinx people to
register and vote and register your
cousin
just register everybody
all right you know there was some
research that came out recently out of
pew
which said that um latino support of the
black lives matter movement is actually
declining
um it was a little bit higher in june
it's a little bit lower
now in september you know what do you
make of that what do you say
what do you say to that yeah i'm not i'm
not sure what the causality of that is
i mean i know i know latinx people are
the most
uh hurt by by covet i i think where my
might be tied with with black americans
uh because obviously we're all latin and
black people are
essential to workers you know making the
food growing the food
serving the food and doing all the
essential services that keep america
functioning i don't know maybe maybe
it's had that has something to do with
it
uh i'm not sure but but black lives
matter
is our sister cause you know i mean
because we're the second group
most shot by police in america and
and we have to support black lives
matter because
first of all it it i can't see another
brother being shot in the back like that
i just can't it just breaks my heart to
note
i just can't bend my heart after that
and i don't want to see that ever again
on a on a slightly lighter note um you i
saw you recently
without yeah just you know lightening it
up a little bit yeah
um you tweeted out happy new year to
those celebrating rosh hashanah
um if i'm not mistaken you live in a
multicultural household
like how how does that kind of
contribute to you know the work that you
do to kind of expand diversity
in the media that we see like does that
influence some of what you think about
oh absolutely absolutely i mean i love
my multicultural family
you know uh mixed race kids are the most
beautiful in the world
and uh and i'm so proud of my my wife is
jewish and my kids are
half jewish little jew ricans um
and and you know we celebrate a lot of
jewish traditions a lot of christian
traditions
we try to add uh you know islam when we
can and
in black traditions uh you just want to
celebrate it all i grew up in new york
city you know the most diverse
place in the world and it made me such a
rich human being you know it really
opened the whole world to me and i want
to pass that on to my kids
and obviously you know when you become a
dad every child
to me becomes my child black asian in
native american white jewish
muslim you know they're all my my
children and i and anybody child that is
hurting or vulnerable
i feel like i have to reach out and do
something about it
well you did mention that you're a new
yorker which you know i knew
so i'm going to throw some rapid fire
new york questions at you
um quickly i probably know the answer to
this but
uh mets or yankees
all the way quiz what do you want i
would i was it was a
child to shea stadium you know uh
yeah my mets my meds are on my team all
right we'll see how they do uh the rest
of the season
um let's see they've won two games in a
row
all right bacon egg and cheese or uh
cart hot dog
the the the bacon egg and cheese on the
kaiser roll from the bolega
with the cafe you know full of milk and
sugar it's like dessert it's not even
there's not barely any coffee in it
exactly the coffee is basically white at
that point
yeah yeah and sugar all right who are
you more scared of a bodega cat or pizza
rat
oh wow i think those bodega cats are
vicious man they've been
fighting you know rats and everything
i wouldn't mess with them very good very
good
so kind of circling back to what we
started off talking about
representation of the latino community
in hollywood
if we sit down and we have this
conversation in five years
what do you think we'll be saying then
how do you think things will look
well i'm really hopeful i feel like this
is a real
reckoning for america i think between
the black lives
matter movement finally taking a hold of
americans conscience
and uh and covet giving us this moment
to really be able to think about things
and have a reboot i think there's going
to be big changes i feel like because
i'm already talking to publishers
who understand that there's a dearth of
latinx content and children need to see
themselves reflected as they are
uh from studios reaching out
i see i see a lot of uh producers
also really thinking about how to make a
difference how to
how how to include more you know and
and i think we're going to see movies
with us in it you know
black and latin people asian people
native american lgbtq
i mean it doesn't have to be just white
males it really doesn't i mean
you you can make a movie with all of us
and still have an incredible
oscar-winning flick
awesome well very well said you know we
could definitely chat with you all day
but i think that's a good place to leave
it
thanks so much for being here and
chatting about a lot of things
it's a pleasure thanks so much muchas
gracias
and hope to talk to you again soon